are you shielding yourself with a pillow
i just found that this works the best
for shielding yourself against enemies
it's like when you go to a dentist and
they put that vest on you
shield you from the magnetic radiation
uh yeah dude i hate that vest you always
feel like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] wearing that vest dude nothing you
can do you're just waiting you're like a
scientific
strong man but a real world
[ __ ] you know we should find those and
wear them
as a fashion statement to our next
comedy gig
yeah it's like a giant metal bib
it's purely utilitarian it feels it does
feel kind of good though it's like
it's comforting yeah you know it's like
a it's like a hug
from a robot it's like
just hangs on you it's like a very like
unfamiliar
type of hug yeah it's robotic
the type of hog where you kind of are
confused
of how you stand at the end of the hog
yeah nothing emotional was solved yeah
it kind of hug where it went on a little
bit too long and you know
maybe you are uncomfortable
yeah it's like two short little arms and
a big
fat wide body it's like so
impractical for everyday use
um but yeah so
[Music]
you are a new regular and kill tony wait
we are thank you we already
talked about that um i don't remember
i don't think so 6 26 is when it
we did our last one um 7
50. oh yeah maybe well i don't think
we're remember
i black out during these podcasts i
don't remember anything i know i'm like
oh it's all on record i don't have to
i don't have to remember yeah but uh
congratulations seriously
thanks man you enjoy it it's
huge unlike your penis
yeah i mean it's like a big show
and it's hard to get and it's like a
yeah
trophy or a medal yeah and it's like one
of the ways that i wanted to make it is
by doing things like kill tony
because that's real that's real comedy
you can't fake it
um but uh
yeah and it puts me on a fast
and as long as i don't [ __ ] it up i
should be good but it's like
i wake up and i'm like am i just boring
like
it's like dude you've been killing it
the comment section loves you
yeah but then i listen to like william
montgomery and david lucas go up and
they get such big pops
yeah like they're good at it and they're
having fun and they're loose and
maybe i'll get there in three years yeah
you definitely will i mean
that's like they've been doing it for so
long they know what a
they know like there's kill tony is like
an open mic to them
even even less like they're like so
familiar
with it like it's like
it's like not even not even like it's
not like an open mic it's just like the
feeling of just like
you you know you're so comfortable where
you are
maybe that's not even true maybe i'm
just making it up they're just like
really in the zone they're like man i
can just say
whatever funny right now and it's just
so smooth and effortless and it's like
on this big stage
yeah um
i mean yeah that's
yeah it's a good show yeah and
hopefully i can get better and like
you know really explore the art form
and the medium of kill tony and to say
something or like to
make a big impact because i don't want
to like squander it i don't want to just
get it and just
like whatever
uh yeah you should actively try to make
the show bad
hey funny you sabotaged the show
yeah i did nothing this week
i just sort of played computer
i just did social media and
went to the grocery store but then if i
said grocery store they could probably
make that interesting somehow yeah i
mean
i guess anything is interesting
yeah if you joke about it wow the uh
is santa on the roof there's a tinkling
and tattling
i said uh
so i think we should keep talking to the
the washer
washer you're not a part of this
conversation you're not in this podcast
you're not on mike washer shut the [ __ ]
up
it's just it's actually the driver
contributing maybe he's mad because i'm
always
uh confusing him with the washer
and he's like i'm not a washer yeah i'm
a driver
it's completely different my my life
you just you think you think all dryers
are the same you know but you think
we're just a bunch of washers
i'm just an appliance to you
how dare you call me a washer
would you call hitler a jew
he washes and i fix his mistakes
um
[Laughter]
can we just like turn it off just be
like
how badly do you need these clothes
right now they're not mine bro
no i mean to ethan
i mean uh we just be like i mean are you
gonna fold it right away
are you just gonna like leave it in a
pile let's just see i'll just see
what it's at i'll be right back
so i've been uh going a lot of mics
i've been doing
a lot of shows but right now it's dried
up
and unlike the clothes
the shows have dried up and i'm just
treading water now
i don't know what i should do what i
should do
is travel to houston and dallas for a
week and do shows and then come back
but then i miss out on the secret shows
which are like so great the secret shows
are like
mini kill tony's
but like the hang is really good
and it's like i get to relive the kill
tony experience on thursdays
and like the people there are amazing
sometimes joe rogan pops in
or shane gillis so there's like a crazy
energy to it
and um kill tony's obviously
are electric it's like when the after
party happens
there's so much partying going on
and free food and cake
is it dry no
but you know he only had it set on like
it was like almost done so like it was
on a timer so technically i didn't even
really do anything
yeah um but that's good
um so
what are we what so what are you um are
you excited are you
are you thrilled about your life are you
uh yeah i mean i feel like a changed man
it's like my life before but
everything's slightly better
it doesn't my life hasn't changed too
much it's like tripping
yeah i think the best thing was that my
van got hit and i got to stay indoors
for a couple of months
um i think that might have helped i
think
shout out to uh rasheeda in idaho
she's in iowa thanks rashida for letting
me stay here
it's really clutch should pay her
we should uh send her like an egg basket
or something
like a cheese egg and cheese
sandwich do you like egg and cheese
sandwiches
i feel like that wouldn't travel well
like the egg would spoil
um maybe get her like
a chocolate or like
you know like a candy cane
yeah and says you're my candy cane
on it yeah did you ever
uh were you over into the valentine's
day thing
no i mean as an elementary school child
we made
we got little cut cardboard cards
yeah and we put them in everyone's
little box
that was fun it was like an art project
um significance yeah so you were cutting
you were making your own
valentine's day cards but so
um what did you make what was it and
then we just buy it like
princess jasmine themed or like
you know snoop this uh scooby-doo themed
um
scooby-doo themed yeah i had the uh
i had the uh i had the star wars
ones and i had like a little lollipop
and i was like you are jedi
knight
you are you are loving
the force on this valentine's day
i love the forest hit by
or is that just a lightsaber in your
pants are you
uh are you a savior for my lightsaber
would you savor the flavor of this
lightsaber
my balls are as hard as bb-8
uh are you jar jar binks because me so
horny
that would be a great one dude for uh
uh a little six-year-old to give
like one of those rhino creatures you
make me horny
it's just it's just funny to me the
image of like uh
a 10 year old or six year old just
giving that
note and not knowing what it means yeah
and they're just eating the lollipop
just oblivious like
like i don't know why that's funny dude
when uh
it's like they're they're like i want to
give you a rim job and
jerk you off yeah like oh look
tommy gave me this oh i got another one
from bobby
uh kids are like i'm gonna give her this
one because it has a rhino on it
dude one time i was uh in in like uh
elementary i remember my first day of
first grade
was it first grade kindergarten first or
second grade
and uh it was like everyone draw
everyone was taking
time to draw on their diaries their
notebooks their journals for the day
and i drew like this guy
holding a wheelbarrow and he's crying
yeah i think i captioned it with like a
paragraph
um it was like a few sentence i don't
know i think it's just like i am sad
today
you lost your innocence yeah that's when
i knew
that i would
have a really good time actually second
day
second day was better second day was
much better
i can't believe you remember this i
guess you're closer to it than i am
all right so wow first grade you
remember
it i remember like clinging to my mom or
my dad
going to kindergarten and then
i was like clinging and then they primed
me off and i was like no
no i don't want to go and i didn't speak
english
i always felt korean uh
and i was holding on to this fact you
didn't speak english no
holy [ __ ] you didn't speak english first
day of first grade
of preschool you keep up at all first
grade was different this is preschool
yeah but you just couldn't understand
anything you're a baby
and you you're just hearing these people
talking a different language
yeah um you know
life is hard um
i'm three years old though so it's not
like they're really
saying a lot it's mostly physical
anyways preschool
there's not a lot of phonics i guess
yeah
you're three i'm pretty sure yeah i
thought priscilla was like five
that's kindergarten what the [ __ ] is why
is there so
many different preschool kindergarten
junior
highs things
uh because we uh tailor
our education to the age
of the students oh dude did you see
do you know malcolm gladwell he has this
thing like uh
where he's like if we if we
like we like determine the schooling
based on age and like
and like he was i forget how he said it
but he's saying like if you're born in a
certain month you're basically [ __ ] oh
yeah
because like you're like the youngest
yeah you're the youngest
you're the smallest and the stupidest
yeah
and it's just like uh the school year if
you're born
on september then you have an advantage
because you're older than all your
classmates yeah but i
maybe it was like maybe it was like not
age that like really
because he was saying like you should
like like there's certain kids who would
like
have that like
special ability like no matter like what
age like they have
like the smartness of like this this age
but it's like the age yeah the age has
nothing to do with it
like we think that it's like uh
i don't even know i'm talking out out of
malcolm gladwell's ass
but like it was some [ __ ] he was just
saying
uh he was just saying something about
that
yeah because the start cutoff starts in
september
so if you have a kid born in september
and then you have a kid born in
august you know like a kid born in
uh september of 2020 versus a kid born
in august of 2021
they all go to the same grade so
one guy is basically a year younger than
everyone else yeah
so he's like developing an a year behind
so they're like oh this guy's just
stupid
but it's just like yeah i'm sure you're
smaller
a year i don't know man yeah everyone
you're around the most you're at a
disadvantage
you're stupider you're smaller and
you're less sexy
uh you are uh
you're less sexy i think that you're
more sexy younger you are
younger like a baby like if you're like
a dude
and you get your pubic hair or like you
know you get facial hair late
then you're like you know stigmatized or
like you're not
we don't know if you're gonna make the
jump yet huh
but like and women or girls if they get
tits first
yeah right it is it is like first about
like getting older
yeah before it is about getting younger
you don't want to be younger
as a kid you want to be younger right
but as a kid in second grade you want to
be like i know how to
run in cursive or drive a car
oh you also get to drive a car light
later
oh yeah yeah um
yeah and it's like what's the solution
and it's like he was saying that
you should uh put kids in schooling like
based on their skill level
or like based on the things they're good
at like like max basically
maximize uh
the skills of humans by like seeing what
people are good at
and schooling them based on like
around that yeah skill or whatever it is
like they're good
and or like yeah like anything i mean
like sexual assault rather than just
like standard education
teaching people the same oh
abraham lincoln was assassinated
nobody gives a [ __ ] okay who cares
um yeah you should be like oh this kid
is good
at putting the blocks in the little hole
we should teach him how to be a
construction worker
yeah or a plunger or a
plumber a
porn star
or this kid is like well you guys got a
huge
we should
put them in a movie but what about like
learning the basics
like it's fun to play with sticks all
day or like climb trees but then like
if you don't know how to add right
right but it's just like up to what
level is like dude
is the basics i mean does the bake does
the basics go all
all the way up to your 18 definitely not
yeah i would say like after
arithmetic plus minus divide
multiply you know like everything else
should be optional
after that right um
or dude or forget
every forget all that like if we have if
we have an athlete
literally have them only do athlete
stuff
but what about addition or like you
don't you want like he's not gonna need
that he's an athlete
but does it wouldn't it help his life
when he's doing taxes or
if he loses his uh ability to do it and
now he has to like
uh you know budget well
we'll have uh i don't know man
because it's like a new thing where
everyone is literate but when you were
illiterate
it was like a thing it was like
it's like dude that guy can't read
like straight up you can't function
like we don't even realize how much
reading we do
every day yeah that's true i'm reading
your aura right now
we're reading each other's body language
um
there's always deaf people i know that
come to juice land
and they have to know how to read to you
know talk to people
yeah that's all they have they like
i wonder if they enjoy enjoy reading
more because they can't hear
yeah they're like oh this movie has
really good subtitles i love the font
look at the sizing
there's like def porn where's like the
subtitles are all sexy
and you know moan groan
bella they they must like emojis a lot
i
i mean know maybe that doesn't maybe
that doesn't make sense
ultimate talking i think i'd much rather
be deaf than blind
definitely dude that sounds peaceful
almost vision is important
being deaf
you don't have to hear this uh dryer
yeah you can just zone out
you're always meditating yeah but
but if you're like crazy if you're deaf
and crazy you're [ __ ]
you know because you can't it's hard
you can't tether yourself to other
people
yeah you have to get your [ __ ] together
um i wonder if deaf people like hear
voices like uh
like they make they i mean
i guess if you if you were deaf like
from the minute you were born
you're never ever hear a sound you think
blind people have hallucinations
i think they're always just seeing [ __ ]
they just have to ignore it
no i don't because i don't think that i
think that you see
because vision takes more vision is like
you have to like it takes
like if it uh you see more details and
stuff the sound you can
sort of make up it's like i mean do you
think
you think you can make it up because
it's so easy for you because you know
what sound
sounds like like imagine never
hearing sound like you don't you have no
way to like
all you have is that image of the guy
and the lines coming out they have deaf
music what the [ __ ] is that what oh like
vibration
can you feel it yeah sure yeah
that's awesome yeah i mean i yeah i
guess if you know what vibrations are
you you kind of have an idea what sound
is oh
he's about to drop the base yeah
bro bro imagine being deaf at an edm
concert all you just
feel is just like yeah
and everyone's like on mali like you
think they're
like i don't know you get like a little
taste of
sound yeah
but what if you're walking and there's a
semi truck coming
and you're like everyone turns around to
look because they can hear it but you're
just like
you have to be really careful if you're
deaf
yeah you have to be constantly looking
at other people's vibes
yeah it's like are they uh panicking
should i be panicking yeah you're like
what should i be doing
which can anyone look at me and tell me
what you guys should we be
running yeah what is the
you just do yeah dude that's crazy man
yeah um
it's like what would we be like if we
were
starfish
probably not as cool
but our brains have the ability to do
that
to find meaning and purpose and being a
starfish
it's just we just happen to be born in
this body yeah
i mean but aren't starfish like really
stupid and
you know just not
yeah but don't you think some people
would strive
more as starfish um
yeah i think i would sure
i think patrick i think i was i was some
people were born
some people were were meant to be a
woman
born a man i was yeah meant to be
starfish
yeah that's why you're always laying
flat as possible
that's why i have such long arms yeah
and i would
just be chilling at the bottom of the
sea a coral reef maybe
i'd hit up like a coral nice coral reef
you'd float i'm like i don't like the
vibes here
can they float yeah they crawled
they do a little bit of both that's so
dope
dude imagine living in the water like
the water is
you're never not in the water
it's two-thirds of the earth yeah
but like the water imagine like yeah
like it's such a crazy feeling
to live in the water yeah there's a it's
a different world
like it's it's different physics yeah
[ __ ] like
your flow it's 3d you're floating oh
there's something about
you can't talk there's no oxygen you
can't speak
yeah i mean you can make like that's why
all their sounds are like sound like
that because they can't do [ __ ]
it's all muffled because water's so
heavy and like birds are like
like birds can like use yeah land
animals like use their mouths
like a aurora alliance roar could never
be
in the ocean
[Laughter]
a lion's wart dude never be in the ocean
riley gilmore
dude and uh sharks don't make a sound
they don't make sound
dude dude imagine that just being like a
[ __ ] murderer beast
and just being silent the whole time
like
yeah it's your whole life is silent but
you're murdering you're basically like
russians
yeah why talk talk stupid i just kill
i kill i don't talk i'm russian shark
i will kill you and to run away silently
swim away swim away
i'm just so used to land i just don't
understand the water at all
like how space is to us that's what
air is oh my god that's what air is to
whatever's to fish and water creatures
what what we are to space yeah
that's a world they say that's like the
closest thing to the world is uh the
underworld the underwater world
or the um
i don't know like the zero g aspect of
it
yeah that's how they train them for
space that's how they train the
astronauts
well i mean water is like so cool
but with water the further down you go
the heavier it is
because you're all that water is you're
carrying it on your head
whatever however that works yeah i don't
think it has that much weight because
i think it's like dispersed like
throughout the ocean
like it's like no like it's like the
pressure
oh yeah it puts pressure for sure yeah
so like all the creatures down there are
like blobby and they don't get any sun
and it's [ __ ] crazy
yeah man they're so blobby dude
because all that they have to like
they're like dude
there's some like that are just so
disgustingly gross like
it's just like their life
i feel like how could you be if you look
that disgusting if major nate
if nature made you look that disgusting
like
there's no way like you're meant to be
like happy
there's no way you're like meant to have
like a good life yeah you think they
feel disgusting yeah i think they do bro
i'm just barely surviving like beauty
i feel like is
i mean it's some it's somehow like
affected by like society but i feel like
it's mostly just like
it comes to naturally it's just like
that's naturally beautiful
this is naturally ugly yeah
and it's like it's not just with humans
it's just with like
the earth you know it's like this is how
the earth tells you you're ugly
by like showing you that it's like
almost dead it looks dead
and gross and and things are crawling
around
but what about like people who are into
metal and like gothic
stuff like to them being ugly and like
dead
is cool like don't you think that
we could have just gone down that path
instead of being like dear
or like [ __ ] oh i'm so beautiful
what else is like a very arrogantly
beautiful like a toucan
a tiger a wolf
yeah uh
but you know
beauty is in the eye of the pew holder
okay uh but yeah i mean who knows beauty
what
what animals are thinking or not
thinking
it's like but i think there is a little
bit of consciousness in animals like
the videos on instagram of the animals
using those buttons
to communicate what do you think about
those
i think that
uh the dogs talking about the dogs yeah
i don't know i've only seen one video i
thought it was just like okay you could
just train a dog to do that
yeah just to press the specific buttons
you want
yeah but wouldn't it also be possible to
have the dog press whatever button they
want to press
uh yeah i mean yeah definitely because
well like if you train them to be like
each button has a certain outcome
yeah they'll learn like food that's easy
yeah or outside right
yeah you could do that yeah for sure so
like when they there's like a video of
this dog who
keeps pressing treat tree
and you can see his personality he's
like
he's like a little schnauzer that's all
dog's personalities
but the little dogs are different the
big dogs are like
i won't treat no but little dogs are
like come on come on come on
hey hey what about me hey come on hey
come on come on guys
hey what are you what do you want what
are you what's going on over here
hey i got some treats or something the
big dog wants treats what a surprise am
i right
this guy's always begging for treats
what about me over here the little guy
this guy's busting my balls over here
literally i'm neutered i'll be here all
night
why is he a comedian
he's a comedian dog convenient he's just
like
a funny guy you know he's a funny guy
hey
i'm a little guy but i'm funny
i'm a little guy but i'm funny so i got
a lot to offer you
yeah you see i got i got
a lot of things going for me you don't
want to kill me i gotta i can help you
out
yeah we could be team we could be you
and us
you want a treat i want to bottle a jack
huh i don't that's probably what they do
they all have little personalities and
this dog is like human
human animal family
i love you
how they think though that's like the mo
that's probably the most i can think
yeah but they can do a little version of
what we do
what's that think communicate
have relationships like if you're in a
wolf pack
they they're like oh i like that guy we
get along but i don't like this guy
and they have like little friendships
some animals are smarter than other
animals
yeah dogs are [ __ ] stupid as [ __ ]
what are you talking about those are the
smartest [ __ ] dude
like they can pull sleds they can you
know they can get
sticks and like fetch and stuff like
that takes higher level thinking there's
a reason why we evolved
right you're right that's a good point i
mean
i mean maybe dude i think they're i
think they're dumb
but we've just we know how to work with
them you know
but wolves are smart as [ __ ] and dogs
come from wolves
yeah we've dumbed them we've i guess
we've kind of like
put them in their place we made them
like
like socially our [ __ ] they're wolf
light yeah
they drink wolf cola we took out all the
cool parts of the wolf
uh yeah well we we tamed
we tamed it we were like you are
have to be like a baby now yeah but i
think it's also selective breeding where
we just picked out the cutest ones
over the years the ones that would not
be so
assertive yeah we chose for like
subservience
yeah so they are dumb and like we can
overpower them really easily
mentally because we selected for that
also we just
we want someone to like us yeah and
wolves don't like us
like you don't like us oh yeah we're
gonna get a version of you that does
that's so creepy oh you ate me [ __ ] you
i'm gonna [ __ ] i'm gonna build a
replica of you
and i'm gonna make it
my [ __ ] but
dogs are super smart i think it's
because like
they're smart in a similar way to us but
in like one way they're
severely lacking like because it's like
they are smarter than any other animal
any other animal we couldn't hang with
like a parakeet isn't as good of a pet
as a dog they're just so smart we're
just so used to them that we're like but
they're the smartest animal
parakeets no dogs what do you mean the
smartest animal
like was it smarter than a dog uh so
many animals
octopus okay but also those aren't like
in our you know that's like very very
small population
monkeys monkeys are not smarter than
dogs maybe chimps are
private why not monkeys yes they are
they have hands
okay well dogs are like good at hunting
together
and like they're very inquisitive
we gave we helped them out they're like
are
morty there are mortys
they got smarter just by hanging out
with us yeah
well i don't know i think they were
already smart like
compared to other animals like you know
cows or chicken or
you know yeah chickens are dumb as [ __ ]
but but no matter how dumb you are you
can still experience pain
and and like trauma
yeah definitely probably bliss too if
you can experience trauma you can
experience bliss but don't you think
they feel it less
than what you do like smarter animals
you can torture
more it's like it takes more of a toll
but a chicken is like i don't want to go
that far i disagree
i disagree definitely it's true like you
can break
a cow or like a pig but like a chicken
it's like no bro no dude they still
feel the pain dude i don't know you
could just
hear them screaming but pigs are more
it's more like a [ __ ] thing scary
it's more scary they're impacted more by
trauma and stuff they remember
[Music]
yeah but like not by death death is like
the same thing
across every scale it's just it's just
pure pain
but to animals i can think it's like a
bigger deal
like you have to be more careful around
a pig then you do a clam
clam murder mystery clams are like
who gives a [ __ ] clams are like murder
me
why don't you no i i disagree dude i
think clams feel
death just as much as pigs i think pigs
can feel it more i think they both
feel it and i think they both want to
avoid it
but i think it's the same thing on
different scales
yeah that's what i'm saying too but like
that doesn't
i mean i don't think it's like
i don't think just because it's like
necessarily
more you know it's more complicated but
it's like
it's it's the same thing you know it's
all the same thing
yeah it's you know death and life
and it's crazy dude how much of that is
like
dude how that's literally the world we
live in is death in life
yeah and it's not even like a necessary
part of it we could just easily not die
but no that's not true but
you have to it's nature bro you don't
have to
like aging like we might die from tigers
or
things but like we don't have to age
it's just like
we do natural selection like physically
there's no reason
like there might be wear and tear but
our bodies like have a shelf life
and our telomeres like short out
like we could have like put some marbles
into longevity but it's like not worth
it what are we how are we supposed to
stop
aging by not like
malfunctioning like not dividing the
cells the correct way
it was just haphazardly done they're
like whatever it will only last 60 years
but it doesn't really matter
how would we do that how do we do that
by
uh making our bodies divide the cells
correctly all the time
no but like uh oh
like is there like it doesn't like
bacteria live like forever
or some some things is there things that
live
um i would have to google it but i know
turtles are like 200
years old or whatever
oh yeah turtles yeah
um but they come from a different
lineage like we come from a different
path of dna
like basically our ancestors our animal
ancestors [ __ ] us
they were like they they evolved the
wrong way
yeah and then not the wrong way but they
evolved in a different way that they
were like
i don't really need to live that long
they went more towards i'm good
production 80 80. i'm good
what yeah they're like
who gives a [ __ ] if i can't [ __ ] by the
time i'm 80
i don't deserve to live everyone says
like old people
[ __ ] a lot you think that's actually
true i think they [ __ ] more than we
think they do dude
like like i can't imagine being an old
person
and finding an old person having to put
on cologne
and wear something nice and go out to
the clubs
like where would you go if you wanted to
pick a puss as an old person
it'd just be so much work well you have
to be rich kind of
it helps to be rich what about the
middle class old person
but you can go to retirement home they
[ __ ]
yeah it's like a frat you're pledging
yeah
this one is the hottest [ __ ]
yeah like like dad why do you want to go
to this one
uh i don't know cocaine's nice
yeah they got a good kitchen and uh
we got a good bingo community
bingo bro did it like did all
you know the old people that play bingo
i'm sure that's not gonna be i'm sure
bingo's not gonna stay around because
there's
like did they play bingo back like when
they were kids and that's why they like
bingo or all of the sudden when you
become old you start liking it yeah
we're gonna have like land parties
instead of bingo
yeah maybe that
but it's like social and like low stakes
and also when you lose you don't feel
bad it's like oh
it's just random it feels like a waste
of time
but it's also like that's how old people
think
it's like oh you just patiently put it
on and then yeah well that's all
oh man oh dude oh people can be so
[Music]
like i'm like what are you doing
we're we're past that that level
of thinking
or not thinking maybe you know it all
comes back
like they go backwards they're like you
know i don't give a [ __ ] anymore i don't
have to think like you
young people yeah i could just
literally just not give a [ __ ]
they just revert to what they really
want
which is just to be watching tv watching
around
making casserole
getting phone calls eating stale cookies
you don't want anything like
high up or high down they just want to
be like but it's like they also can't do
much
you know your your body is like
literally [ __ ] you over yeah
so you're like what's the best way to
just lounge around
what's the best way to do anything you
have to love
it's like it's not like they want to you
have to
ah you have to rest that's with their
breasts when you're sick because they're
like
you can't go out now you gotta yeah
isn't that the worst and you're like
you're like while you were not sick
you're like
oh i just want to be lounging around and
while you're sick you're like i don't
want a [ __ ] lounge
yeah and like you're just like i want to
get out there i don't want to be stuck
in the air
yeah i mean i haven't been sick that
much
so usually i don't want to do something
i do it
i was sick a lot as a child really
but a lot of times i was also like
forcing myself to be sick
because i wanted i didn't want to go to
school
that's smart so you that's my
boy my mom even that guy what that was
your identity that you're the sick guy
yeah oh riley he's the guy that's always
sick no there was more [ __ ] there was
like
there's kids who were out like [ __ ]
months
because they were just sick dude what
happened to your generation
no there's only a few kids this those
were the really sick kids what were you
gonna say
there was one kid who was so sick that
he
had this like robot with like
it was like probably like a five five
foot tall
robot like a
machine like going around and had
like a a video of him on the screen
and he would just be like like bro like
moving to classes on the robot it was
like it looked like
kind of like a bishop in chess it like
moved
like on across the floor like a vacuum
and he was a giant roomba yeah yeah
he's sitting on a roomba like a five
foot tall roomba
is he there and he was just why does he
just have a wheelchair like everyone
else
because he's sick he had to stay home
he's like an iron oh
it was like a oh yeah so he was
virtually attending classes
yeah and uh and it would just be like
it'd be like guys you guys the robot's
coming the road was coming because you
could just see
you can just see it hi guys
[Music]
why doesn't someone just have a video
camera somebody like push them to the
ground
[ __ ] you rubber
my god that's how they should do
coronavirus school from now on every kid
gets a little robot and then they can
[ __ ] with the robots yeah put little
penises
that's that's what they the kids really
want these days
it's just control things from a screen
dude why does why don't they just have a
guy holding a camera
just be like oh what can you hold this
camera and point it
they don't need a [ __ ] rope because
then they need to hire a guy
no they could just get a student who's
already going to all this class then the
student would have to like spend all of
their time with this kid
and he'd be like dude he's like he's
like dude i'm gonna put you down for a
second i'm gonna go
talk to ashley i'll i'll be back in a
second
exactly you can just keep him at the yo
i just ditched that camera kid
dude there's no reason for a robot that
is ridiculous
uh yeah it was pretty it was pretty
extra but like
yeah i guess it was just like really
sick
i don't know maybe that was his like
make-a-wish child has a right to go to
school
that was just make-a-wish she wanted to
be a robot
at school
please make me a robot
um did girls go up and talk to him
they're like oh that's kind of cool he's
a great here's a couple grades below me
the robot was uh
did you ever come back and people were
like we want the robot back
imagine it was like everyone's laughing
it was like haha in the room and the
robot wheels in
everyone stops immediately yeah oh hey
robot
we're just having some human fun
and he's like uh yeah they're like
he can't do things that humans do like a
swimming pool he's just watching from
screen
like come on in robot
oh yeah you can't you'll [ __ ] die
uh dude but i hope he's all right man
yeah hopefully hopefully he graduated
and and educated
hopefully he's in robot college
where everyone's a robot this is how you
oil your gears
dude hopefully he's a drone now
he's up and drone heaven that's a drone
now
hopefully he's bombing some kids in iraq
right now he got a job as a
military drone right
he got recruited by military hey you're
a fine young robot
how'd you like to be a drone kid look at
that metal
some tough metal
dude there was kids who were like shy uh
signing up for the army in high school
like the army would like straight up
come to my high school
and like get kids to sign up i was like
dude that's kind of [ __ ]
yeah who knows if that's a good choice
yeah to make kids and like and the kids
would do it just to like brag to their
friends like yo just sign up for the
army
they're like yo that's so sick
so badass man this is the people you
come from
what this is your heritage what are you
talking about bro
i signed up for the army i didn't do it
i don't know it's just funny like put it
on tick-tock
you know i'm a basic training right now
ah
yeah yo gang gang for the army
can i get them can i get 18 likes for
the army
dude uh worst part of the army is they
won't let us vape
sucks here they won't even let us
like like just like do heroin
anymore back in the army you could just
do heroin
and that's idea it's fine
did i mean i think i could handle the
army except for the sleep deprivation
everything else is fine
i think my neck is too broken to do any
physical neck is broken
yeah oh i have a herniated disc
what is that it means that
part of the fluid and my
disc is leaked and it's pressing on a
nerve
why don't just put it back in okay
can you do it for me what did the doctor
say
he said the fluids out i mean they can
do surgery or
and just learn to live with it does it
hurt always
uh yeah
how much is a surgery i don't know
so you're you don't want us to get
surgery
uh it's just kind of scary but yeah we
get surgery
well uh
what type of fluid is it is it like blue
i think it's like red or pink
well it's already out by now you know
what are they gonna clog it up
yeah they're just gonna push it back in
oh so it's like not really that fluid
yeah it's just in like a bubble
i'm guessing it's solid if this fluid
it'd be done by just try to suck it back
up
with your fist like
like try to suck with your disc
are you getting it i think you're
getting it
it helps a little bit
is it like a milkshake it's like dude
it's too thick to suck in
the pipes clogged
i can't get air to my herniated spinal
disc
you know what's crazy is how awesome the
bong is now after i cleaned it
yeah that [ __ ] was so clogged
and if we didn't have that bong all that
[ __ ] would be in her throat in our
bodies
like all that is in our bodies i know
but a lot of lining my lungs are lined
with that stuff i know it's so bad for
you
but it's good for
[Music]
your status your social status
it's good for your brain in that you
become a lot healthier
and happier that's not true
you don't think weed is good for your
brain uh
no i don't i don't i don't think it's
bad for you in small doses
but i think like if you do it a lot i
think it
can [ __ ] up your brain
it's [ __ ] up my brain for sure i mean
i can still function and like be a human
but like
i would not be my brain would not
function the way it does
if i didn't smoke this much weed this is
not a good thing
uh i mean
i don't know what do you mean by good
normal
like if you didn't smoke i think i would
be like higher functioning if i didn't
smoke weed
but why aren't you higher functioning
just
to begin with like if you if you were
fine you wouldn't have needed weed
if you're just happy
yeah i mean i mean i think that
weed helps you feel happy i'd be on a
higher
frequency maybe not maybe i wouldn't be
higher functioning
but i think i definitely would because i
mean
really because yes you were sober it
makes me like sleepy
that alone but maybe it's good to sleep
not as much not i feel like if we can
make me sleepy i'm probably not getting
enough sleep
and it's a good thing that weed reminded
me and then i sleep and i feel more
refreshed
and also i think like weed is like
helps you gain another perspective on
the world like we're so
used to the just tired and hungry and
whatever
aspects of weed that we forget like when
before we smoked weed
like we were not you know
looking at the world the same way we are
now and we owe a lot of that
to weed because like if sober people
sober people are like they they don't
know like perspective they're just like
oh this is my life and it's really
important that i get this done but with
weed you're like
i am just one in a million or whatever
like
like you can observe your
what you're doing outside of yourself
you're like oh i'm at the mall right now
let's act like i'm at the mall that kind
of stuff the sober people
never get a break from just being stuck
behind their eyes
and uh there's a lot that we gained from
weed that we just take for granted but
yeah i mean yeah i'm tired sucks no
i i see what you're saying but it's like
hyper it's like it's like hyper uh
awareness yeah
but do you think that's a good thing i
mean
well i mean if you're getting too much
of it obviously it's not a good thing
but i think if you get the right amount
it's good and i feel like you strive
under that because you're like
uh hyper-aware and you're like just
criticizing yourself and
making it funny and you're good at being
uh
self-conscious and unsure and you're
like making it funny
but maybe there's i don't want to say
like that's all there is to you is like
being a goofy idiot but i mean you're
good at it sometimes
i know
uh but i want i mean i want to be
smarter
i would like to be a smarter guy
sounds nice in the mic no you think
don't you think there's intelligence to
how you
like only in that it's the opposite of
what everyone how everyone else thinks
because they're smarter
um i think like maybe you're just like
unsure
i mean i don't know what you are but
maybe you're unsure of things and you're
like
always questioning and it's good to have
that instead of everyone just being
irrationally confident for no reason
huh but i mean it i mean
why not be confident you know
why would you why be insecure why is it
being insecure good
because most of the world is unknown
and we can't predict the future so it's
good to be adaptable
yeah i guess
yeah it's gonna be adaptable for sure
but i'm not saying that you're you lack
confidence
uh okay
i'm just trying to psychoanalyze you for
no reason you are on a couch
time's up all right
we did an hour
felt like a million hours
so uh
is it good to have a podcast but uh that
by the end of the
podcast you're broken
we led them around in circles
um but uh
what's your favorite thing about
podcasts
um the fact that it's like
you're in a group of friends without
having to do any other work
to gain friends or to go outside or put
on pants
that's what you like about it yeah it's
like oh friend time
let me put on my friends friend time
yeah
friend time put on so michael jackson
says
frame time yeah i'm trying to have some
friend time
have you been watching a lot of michael
jackson i don't even know how i talked
oh is that every time i just watched
south park
yeah uh yeah michael jackson i don't
know why you say i did these things
i'm just a singer hey you can't tell me
that that's really me
that's my version that's really
hey you can't call me that that's really
mean
that seems like his whole career at the
end it's just like
i remember i sing songs
that's so mean you guys i'm really
hurting my feelings
there's something to me i'm just trying
being be a good boy
i just like kids black kids and hanging
out with kids and
playing with kids
you know being around kids
why are you gonna make me feel so bad
well uh i mean i don't blame them you
know adults could be [ __ ] [ __ ]
kids on the other hand are always fun
you know have you analyzed the benefits
of kids
pros innocences they love
candy they always want to stay up late
they like everything
they say the darndest thing they say
darndest things
uh they hate vegetables
they hate authority yeah
they do whatever they want they're the
life of the party
carpe diem they live everything bro they
really
are the life of the party you bring a
kid to a party they know
how to party bro everyone's talking to
the kid dude
everyone wants to be around the kid dude
yeah they're like tell us more
tell us how to be us yeah they're closer
to nirvana they're closer to god
yeah is what they are like oh look they
don't they smile when they want to smile
they say whatever they're like holy [ __ ]
this guy is insane
bro this guy doesn't give a [ __ ] this
guy doesn't give a [ __ ]
he's just [ __ ]
this guy just [ __ ] himself yo
this guy just ate pudding with his hands
he put it all over his face
bro this guy just threw his plate
dude michael jackson was probably having
the best parties
hey guys all the kids are around dude
it was probably like a like like imagine
a rave
but all kids it's like 5 000 kids just
screaming
just michael jackson on stage in his
underwear
are y'all ready to party
we are ready to get [ __ ] up your faces
are right at his dick
he's not so watching no his screen you
know the big screen that raves is just
his dick
those poor kids uh
i mean i honest i believe that they
weren't raped
really yeah i think there's a strong
possibility that they were not raped
but there's also strong i think he raped
like three
or two yeah it's not like yeah maybe
just by accident one night
yeah i don't think it was a big deal it
was like like it was like smart it was
like hey so listen
don't tell the guys about that
yeah sorry that was weird last nap time
a little wet
holy [ __ ] dude but like i don't i think
like
i think he's just a guy i think he's
just
dude like i i think a rapist
is not someone like that you know rapist
is like
look at a guy who's act like a
just with more confidence no like more
more no not more confident like more
dark and
you know they want to take they just
want to take you know they're
they're just dark figures they're like
they're like manly men
almost maybe not manly men but like they
they know what they want from the world
and they're gonna go get it
they're they're really yeah like
aggressive but michael jackson was like
i love you can you guys love me i'll do
whatever you want
do you guys want to go on my slide i got
a slide
he was like beaten by his dad so yeah
bro he's [ __ ] up dude
i think he just wanted to be a kid
yeah he's like trying to get my haircut
the child that he lost
as an adult but he has an adult penis
that thing always gets in the way i hate
my penis
oh i hate my feet i just hate my adult
penis
i wish i had a child's child's dick
can i just put yours in my mouth
can i see yours for a second
you can't try to be a child when you got
adult balls pumping all that
testosterone in you
i like your baby penis
anyways should we add that i'm hungry
yeah should we get some
peanut some baby broccoli
and some baby grapes leave it in our
mouths and
baby spinach let's just get all baby
let's have a baby night
let's just get all baby foods food make
a baby salad
play baby by justin bieber
uh hit me baby one more time baby
get an actual baby get an abortion
the uh abortion dude the abortion
based on the abortion abortion i saw
planned parenthood and it was like all
it was like it was like the structure
was there but everything outside was
like everything on the inside was like
taken out i was like oh it got aborted
like it literally got aborted how do you
like it yeah
it was like like this it was just
desolate inside but the structure was
there
yeah i was like wow sad
i mean it's good that we have planned
parenthood i was like thank god there
was another planned parenthood to get
your
planned paranoid aborted there will only
be one planned parenthood at the end
whose joke is that you can't abort
that's shane gillis
no that's can't abort that planned
parenthood
because it's only one you can't abort
yourself
um so uh
yeah so thanks for listening
subscribe subscribe
thanks for listening to the wink and the
stink
all right let's come up with a name like
right now let's come up with a name
right rotisserie
style uh midnight hour
midnight gossip midnight gospel
that's duncan trussell oh yeah let's see
your channel
how about twilight open the cabinet that
was just something
i thought about doing surf the web
uh twilight council
the twilight hyundai elantra
sports all about sports
sports talk is not already podcast
all about sports sounds good a-a-s
jame dude yeah that'd be funny if we
named it like a sports thing and then
the sports people watched us and they're
like they're doing philosophy [ __ ]
the [ __ ] is this we should do philosophy
[ __ ]
we do that's what this podcast is what
the podcast should be called
we do philosophy [ __ ] or philosophy [ __ ]
how about
phil phil about
no uh how about
philharmonic orchestra
maybe not that howabout.com.com
yeah i don't know man this [ __ ] it's
so hard to come up with a name and like
stick to a name we i know we already had
one
it was so good you just had to squash it
for no reason
because i don't think it's uh
a good idea especially now that you're
on kill tony
what i would love to be called
the [ __ ] of the pink again
all right well let's let the audience
just let's let twitter decide
hey twitter what do you think about this
one we should do one of those polls
well dude i mean it's just is there a
korean
like slang word we can use um
[ __ ] is that just a general asian the
[ __ ] and the spook
because i'm whiter than a ghost
book how about tabuki
the [ __ ] tabuki
try my cookie cook
so uh how about the
bloop in the blue blop let's dip in the
shop
okay step in the stuff how about just
[Music]
like prince how about just all right
yeah how about just hey y'all
hey y'all that's good let's do that one
hey y'all
yeah that's a good one but we're not
wait neither of us say y'all yeah
well we can start i say hey all the time
i thought i was picture just more of a
high guy
speaking of which all right
thank you so much